trois deux un zéro
allumage  la première étape la première
étape accélère, il y a l'appel d'
accord, l'activité principale arrive dans un
peu plus de 10 secondes, arrêtez et faites glisser
une évasion du pied
[Applaudissements] d'
accord, vous venez de voir un flash de frein là-bas, on
dirait peut-être Falcon neuf et  là,
vous venez de voir le coffre larguer à nouveau
des acclamations très fortes ici à
Hawthorne en Californie, c'est dur
et les voilà, les chutes de drogue sont sorties
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une chose vraiment excitante à voir
parce que nous avions le temps n'était pas
vraiment sûr que si le temps allait
coopérer, nous essayions de faire